wait so you and your wife this is
amazing 26th anniversary y'all just
celebrated uh well last summer 26 we're
coming up incredible yeah we can't
there we are
yeah do you still at this point do you
still do gifts or is it like I mean what
do you get each other at this point uh I
got her a sloth and she's so stoked
about it no I we we have not re it's one
of those things where she's tried a
bunch of time to buy me clothes and uh
she's like I'm not gonna try but I for
my birthday uh she got me Brian you know
Brian Cox from succession on HBO yeah he
got a cameo of him telling me to
off and that was
I was like I I kind of cried a little
bit I was like this is the greatest
thing I've ever received as a gift what
a perfect counterpart for you she was
like here you go uh I think you're funny
I bought her a coat last week where I
just kind of saw it and I was like this
looks good and I purchased it it arrived
and she was like this actually works
nice it was a surprise it's hard to do
clothes for other people it is yeah yeah
but yeah and she's always like oh this
is actually good as if it everything
else was crappy and so she she likes it
so yeah we we've been we started dating
our first date was in like in 93. so
yeah when the photographer was not even
born and yeah we we look at each other
we're like what what happened where did
all this we don't we signed
this day when I get in bed with her I'm
like I'm in bed with a lady
look at her what happened and uh I love
that's why you're still together that's
awesome yeah at least you're not looking
ever going you again she does that
her eyes can roll all the way over and
she doesn't really well she laughs at
like every 50th joke yeah and she'll be
like oh that was funny because she's
used to you well she probably knows what
joke you're going to say before you say
it well sometimes or I'm just
relentlessly annoying uh but I like
dated a girl once that laughed at
everything I said and I was like this is
weird but I shouldn't be winning this
much I know but you're funny that's not
that's on you not her yeah yeah yeah
that's your fault yeah that was Nicole
Kidman that's good
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]